health ways and means committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
covert 19 pandemic
in the accordance with the house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public party is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a work session
and possibly executive session
please note that there is no physical
location for members
of the public to observe and listen
contemporaries to this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporarily
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice of this meeting complies with
the house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs at
lake.state.nh.us.com
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting
assisting us jennifer four the committee
researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
representative bernstein would you take
the attendance
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you and good morning everyone
it's march 11 2021. 905 am we'll begin
roll call with representative patrick
abrami
here muhammad stratham my wife is in the
house younging in for mary griffin today
is representative troy murray
uh representative murder just tell us
you're here and say good morning
you have to unmute yes i was beautiful
sorry yeah i'm president alone
thank you representative ovary uh
present
in the house in hudson and my wife is uh
wandering around
also from hudson representative russ
ober
president hudson at home with the six
cats
representative doucette good morning
from my home office in salem alone good
morning
your clerk is alan bershteen and i'm
here in nottingham new hampshire in my
home office by myself
representative robert elliott dear and
my wife is in the living room
good morning representative john
genigeon
i'm here in salem and my wife is
somewhere in the house
did i get your ninja in right it's
actually hard g
all right next time i will get
apologies no problem some time together
john
because i i have a hard time
no problem representative new nades
good morning mr clerk good morning
colleagues i'm home alone in pelham
good morning representative baxter thank
you mr clerk i'm home alone
representative spillsbury good morning
home alone in charlotte
good morning from northwood
representative paul tudor
good morning i'm uh here in the summer
uh by myself my wife's upstairs
representative susan army
at home alone in lebanon representative
richard ames
i'm here and jeffrey home alone
from the wonderful city of dover
representative thomas southworth
home alone and dover representative
malloy
dennis malloy representative schamberg
sandberg is in new london and his truck
headed to wilmington
representative tucker
representative tucker representative
gomarlo
aaron swansea alone representative
thomas laughman
representative representative amanda
gorg
good morning i am present and alone
good morning representative mary hacken
phillips
morning i come to you from my office in
concord alone
representative james murphy good morning
i am
alone in my home office in hanover
and our chair representative norman
major
good morning i'm in my office my home in
plasto
my wife is in the house good morning mr
chair there are 21 members present
three or not
thank you representative bernstein
that's better
a couple of announcements
um yesterday we had the hearing
with representative michael voss
on house bill 6 614
now he sent me an email last night also
sent it to the clerk
i feel i need to go over this with the
committee
so it says mr clerk during my testimony
yesterday before the ways of means
i discovered that the amendment for the
science and technology and energy adopt
for house bill 614 which the house
says passed was the wrong amendment
we adopted amendment 2021-1568
but meant to adopt 20 20 21
0 2 2 8. i haven't had time to look at
the
recorded executive session to see how
this error
occurred the question now what do we do
is it appropriate or possible to ask
ways and means to adopt an amendment to
fix this error
what other options do we have to save
this bill thank you
that's from representative ross to the
clerk with a poppy to me
and this morning i get a email from
a clerk paul smith with a copy to
michael ross
good morning technically ways and means
isn't meant to deal with policy portions
of the bill
but rather the tax implications
if the amendment would have implications
on that
i'd suggest that you discuss it with the
committee as soon as possible
so they know what to work with i also
think
in order to make the necessary change
you
you'll likely want to have file a floor
amendment to the bill
when we have the next in session and
address it there
best paul so
i just want you to be aware that
when you read the bill as amended that
amendment wasn't the right amendment
so all right the other thing i want to
make you aware
is that next week i've scheduled
public hearings
on tuesday the 16th
as we we now have six senate bills
that have come to us senate bill
22 relatives the sale of 47 tickets
and get this
also senate bills 25
titled relative to char uh i'm sorry
senate bill 27 relative to the sale of
left clicking
i haven't read them yet with the same
relative code so i'm scheduling them
both at the same time
senate bill 23 changing the requirements
that a member
of the sponsoring charitable
organization be present during the
during certain games of chance senate
bills 25
relatively charity gaming licenses
senate bill 48 relative the formula
used to determine current use tax rates
and senate bill 103 nexus provisions for
certain disaster related or emergency
related
work performed in the state so those are
the bills that we'll have
the public hearing on next tuesday so
if you can download those and get
familiar with those before that
and then the following two days
the 17th and 18th
we'll be updating revenue estimates
finance is really in a pickle
they want our revenue estimated
estimates updated asap
and we will do them asap in a logical
manner
and we're starting today looking at all
the things
associated with house bill 2.
and also also associated with house bill
is the
single sales factor house bill
281 which they want to fold into house
bill 2.
so that's what we'll be concentrating on
later today also today
we would like to be able to
agree on house bill 15
and get that exec out and that's our
last remaining
first session bill
then we have the six bills that we had a
public hearing on
uh waiting we'll execute those at a
later time
so that's what our schedule is so what i
wanted to do is that everybody received
i believe it was yesterday
[Music]
from the dra their updated revenue
estimates
go over those and then that'll be the
basis of where we start
when we do revenue lessons next
wednesday and thursday
all right
mr chair yes do you know if those of us
that have property on current use will
be able to participate
in the senate bill debate on current use
or is that a conflict
what you do is make sure that
that's so noted
because i i also have property and
current years too
so i think when it comes to
i'm gonna have to check with you with
paul on that
jordan yes i think all you need to do is
declare
that you have a conflict of interest
and then you get to choose whether you
feel comfortable
acting on it individually if it affects
you no more or less than any other
person
in a certain similar circumstance once
you declare that there's a conflict
you should be able to uh participate in
uh
discussion of the bill and and even
voting on it
yeah i believe you're right but i'm just
going to
verify that with the clerk and the
speaker yeah
mr chair long ago on
they told us that at a time when about
25 of the people smoked that
smokers could vote on
on the the smoking bills because
on 25 is a lot of the population
and i think that there are quite a few
people with current use
i don't have it but
well i'll find out and i i think what
jordan said
is correct but
any other questions before we proceed
yeah it's pat um
so what's the plan for the six bills
that we heard yesterday
in terms of work session would it be the
following week
it would be the following week okay
we need to we really need to get these
revenues out
with uh can and they would like to have
them now
i know and they have to work with our
revenue estimates
right my only concern is the uh some of
the some of the bills we heard yesterday
are gonna need some work
i mean i guess we can retain them too
but um anyway we'll leave it at that
anything else
okay then
what i'd like to do is
open the work session on house bill 15
and if we can uh feel that
the exact session then we'll do that
right after that so on house bill 15
we'll open the work session on that
i just have to get my hospital 15.
house bill 15 and act relative to
including under the meals and rooms
tax facilitators of internet
transactions and motor vehicle rentals
and facilitators
internet transactions room occupancy and
we're
dealing with amendment
20-20-21-1
[Music]
sponsored by representative baxter and
we had a discussion with that yesterday
how does the do we have any further
questions
if we don't does everybody feel we can
go into an executive session
yes all right then
we will go into executive session on
house bill 15.
do i hear a motion
mr chair i'd like to make a motion yes
uh representative thank you mr chair i'd
like to make
make a motion to pass my amendment um
hb zero five nine nine and we back up
we have to make a motion on the bill
first and then make a motion on the
amendment
immediately after that understood
the motion representative baxter
then mr chair i'd like to make a motion
to pass hb
15. representative baxter
makes otp on house bill
15 second
i'll second that mr chair represent
nunez
thank you mr chair and i'd like to make
a motion to pass my amendment
hb uh 2021-0599
also second that motion mr chair okay
just let me finish my writing
okay the motion on amendment 059998 is
ought to pass
by representative baxter second by
representative newman's
uh any discussion representative
baxter
mr chair would you like me to speak to
the motion yes
thank you mr chair um as i
talked about with the committee
yesterday the purpose of the amendment
is to clarify any lingering doubt that
remained about travel service
agents um being taxed
which was not the intent of the bill
so i know we have a large uh support
among the committee members for the bill
and this amendment
which was written by dra alleviates
that last lingering concern among some
of the committee members including
myself
as well as other stakeholders and
interest groups
so i'm hoping that we can get
support for the amendment today and i'm
happy to answer any questions if
if any committee members have a question
about the amendments though
any further questions or comments on the
amendment
further questions or comments on the
amendment i see none
whoops you gotta
thank you yes i'd like to
uh i'm speaking in in
opposition to the amendment and
first it was reference made by
representative baxter to
dra having drafted the amendment i think
uh it should be clear that the dra
is not offering the amendment as a
proposal
they did this for the representative
and expressed
their views on the amendment which
included
the concern that it would create
confusion but they thought they could
probably address that through
rule making that's what they said
i hope i'm characterizing it correctly
and for me um i think the
uh confusion generated by this amendment
is totally unnecessary
that the bill is drafted is
the original bill as drafted is
is just right and what is being created
by this
amendment is the significant potential
for
um an interplay between
the occupant
and the room facilitator
um i think that's right
between the operator and the travel
agent excuse me sorry
and the what is
taxable is the full
retail price charge for occupancy
which is what an operator
will be paying but what is not taxable
is the
[Music]
travel agent's commission or
compensation
and if you uh if you move some of the
money into the travel agent category it
is
um is no longer taxable um
and there will be an incentive to do
that it's
it's unnecessary the original bill the
text of the original bill makes clear
that the full
retail price charged for occupancy
is what's taxable let's leave it at that
and not confuse the issue but trying to
put in
something that addresses essentially a
non-issue as far as i'm concerned
thank you thank you
james representative malloy
thank you mr speaker i concur with uh
representative ames
assessment of this i think it just adds
a layer of confusion
this bill in its various forms has been
in this committee now for a couple of
years
a lot of people have worked on this very
hard
uh several of the people that sponsored
this bill are in this committee right
now and uh
uh speaker packard is the prime sponsor
and the bill that we presented i think
is clean
it answers all the questions and um
to representative ames point is that
uh uh i think we're adding a level of uh
confusion and i also concur that
that even though dra uh helped work on
this i don't know that that is meaning
that that's a
uh they don't endorse anything but i
don't know that that's uh
uh relevant uh to this conversation
because the bill itself is a good bill
and i will not be supporting the
amendment thank you
representative baxter thank you mr chair
and i just want to thank representatives
malloy and ames for their comments
um i do just want to speak to uh what
they said
um it wasn't just um
worked on it was 100 written by dra
so it is even though i'm putting forth
the amendment
it was written by dra and i do want to
speak to what representative ames said
about
it was dra's belief that it creates
confusion
that's not 100 accurate to my
understanding
carolyn who wrote the amendment said it
has the possibility
um to create confusion i think that'd be
a better way to paraphrase what she said
because she said any amendment could
theoretically the new language
lead to something but she is comfortable
and that's her own words she's
comfortable with the amendment
as written uh which isn't surprising
because she wrote the amendment
so while she may not feel it's necessary
because she believes the current
bill is okay she also is comfortable
with the amendment
um and while everyone on the committee
might not share their concern
that there's the issue with travel
service agents
being taxed um without that that
original intent there are committee
members and stakeholders that feel that
way
so this amendment is a way to prevent
um and address that concern while doing
it in a responsible way
um and that's why we have we've done
multiple drafts and i worked with the
dra so
we could have an amendment that they are
comfortable with so
i'm not quite sure what the harm is um
and that's hopefully that addresses um
what the representatives have brought up
thank you mr
chair representative
thank you mr chin on
we could have handled this the way it
should have been handled which
is just by putting something into the
blurb which
is a legal signal to both the jail car
and any court case on about the travel
agents
and this does
put in a measure that would be
able to be played with whether they've
been in court or not on buy
on various businesses
and on
i want the bill to pass but on
i hope that it can be clean thank you
any further comments or questions
on the amendment
any further questions or comments on the
amendment saying none i'm going to ask
the
clerk to call the vote on the amendment
if you're in favor of the ought to pass
on the amendment
respond by yes if not respond by no
thank you mr chair um the amendment
is
nine nine 2021-05998 we'll begin the
roll call vote for this amendment to
hb-15
with representative patrick abrami yes
representative troy mirner yes
jordan owerry representative ovary
find the microphone yes representative
ober
yes clerk votes yes representative
doucette
yes representative elliott yes
representative genigean yes
representative nunes yes representative
baxter
yes representative spillsbury
no
representative tutor yes
representative no
representative ames no
representative malloy phil
another order there i apologize
representative southward
no representative schamberg
no representative tucker
not voting representative gomarlo
no representative lofton
no janitor
no representative
hacken phillips no
representative murphy no
chairman major yes
mr chair the final vote is 12
voting yes 11 voting no one member did
not vote
the motion carries uh
was the member president that did not
vote
it's representative tucker so no she is
not present
okay mr chairman i can't find her
okay the vote being 12 to 11 the amen
the amendment 0.5999
passes so
what we're now discussing house bill 15
with amendment
any
questions or comments
representative
amber oh schanberg i'm sorry
uh mr chairman uh since i'm in
opposition to this motion will i get a
chance to speak
against the motion i've just recognized
you
thank you sir
representative schamberg is presenting a
minority position
in opposition to this bill i believe on
february 10th i oppose this bill
because i believe it creates new taxes
and new regulations
and today i find that i still must
contend that house bill 15
is creating a new tax with more
government regulations
with the amending of the definitions
under meals and rooms rsa 78-a
colon 3 roman numerals 6
13 and 18. i
strongly believe house bill 15 initiates
a new tax when placed on goods and
services
when included in a bundled package for
rental of a room
if i reserve a room for one night at the
inn on pleasant lake in new london for
249 dollars
my rooms and meals tax would be 22.41
but if the inn says instead of you
making a call to ragged mountain or
mount centipede
for skiing arrangements the inn says we
have an arrangement with the mountains
to offer you a winter sports package
for another 180 dollars so that you will
be guaranteed lift tickets
skis helmet and a reserved spot for
skiing
guess what happens under house bill 15
this bundled package approach
is now considered to be part of the
rooms and meals tax
because it comes with the room and thus
increases the amount
of the meals and rooms tax to be charged
with this new definition
a tax increase i say yes if you don't
ski
say you want to take advantage of a
flower arrangement package for the room
for your special someone and a spa
treatment just like the sports package
for skiing
this will fall under the new rooms and
meals tax definition
because it comes with the room and an
increase in the amount of the meals
and room tax to be charged under the
amended definitions
if these items would be purchased
separately in the hotel lobby
or call the ski mountains on your own
there would be no rooms and meals tax
that is connected to the room so if
house bill 15 is implemented with the
amended definitions
but presently doesn't have a sales tax
on it now will be included as part of
the meals and rooms tax
because it is part of the bundled
package included
with the room and since this bill mr
chairman
is also dealing with car sharing
platforms i feel that once again
house bill 15 is changing the
regulations to tax this peer-to-peer
approach
being peer-to-peer is not about tourism
and is not like a car rental company
we are talking about individual car
owners trying to cover expenses by using
a public bulletin board this
peer-to-peer public platform
does not own or operate any fleet of
vehicles
they do not take possession or control
of a customer's car
they are public bulletin boards for
connections
if house bill 15 is implemented it seems
that this bill
would require me the car owner the host
to register with the dra and post a
business license
what happened to promoting the
entrepreneurial spirit are we going to
tax citizens who simply
want to share their personal property
with another person
potentially within their community mr
chair i present a rhetorical question
what is the difference between taxing
peer-to-peer car sharing
under the rooms and meals tax and me
individually speaking with my neighbor
to borrow a pickup truck to do yard work
and filling their truck up with gas when
i am done
that is consideration paid for the use
of a vehicle
it is this a transaction subject to
taxation
if it isn't done over the internet can a
transaction be taxed
because it is done over the internet
here in new hampshire
yet other similar transactions won't be
subject to taxation
i find that house bill 15 as applied to
peer-to-peer sharing over the public
platform
seems to be as i said before on february
10th
auntie entrepreneurial i would now
include that house bill 15 seems to be
anti-innovation and even anti-green
i feel that if this committee chooses to
amend the law
to tax online platforms the meals and
rooms tax
with this house bill 15 i believe is a
new tax with a new regulations
mr chairman i stand in opposition to
house bill 15.
thank you testimony representative
representative
thank you mr chairman on representative
schamberg has brought together
a number of new accusations
uh i do not know if we have the
capability
of uh suspending while we listen to the
dra respond to them
one of them is that packages
would be taxed on because of this bill
packages have never been taxed on of
skis or flowers or whatever under
uh the rooms and meals tax i do not
believe that it is possible that they
would be taxed
with this bill in place but uh the dra
is in the audience on the other one
is relative to innovation
on when you innovate in a way that
you are still providing the service but
you
are evading the tax on
that has been in place for a long time
on that kind of service
on our law has to be altered
to include equivalent services
that have changed due to innovation
if we don't do that we are creating a
situation
where people who are providing the
service in a more traditional way
have a double
on competition against them
and that is what you are advocating for
as far as i can tell on i would like
to ask if there is some way that we can
ask the dra
to to respond thank you
i'm going to uh honor that
you just checked the attendees
carolyn melissa and devon yeah
carolyn gavin and melissa
mr chairs is the proper procedure to uh
ask for because where the motion has
been made hasn't it
i think we we may have to have the
motion withdrawn
otp as amended to be safe you're right
um then we can go back into executive
session after we hear from
the dra would
the motion about to pass
with the amendment representative baxter
and representative nunes would you
want to withdraw your emotion now
okay and mr chair if i may the reason i
say that is because
we've been working on this for numerous
sessions now
so i feel like we've got a pretty good
understanding of what this bill does
i i uh mr chair i i actually agree with
representative varmy that
i think the dra can um address
all the points that uh representative
schomburg brought up
uh and help help your cause actually
represent a baxter but
um that's all we're trying to do
you're going to be allowed to make your
motion again it's just a proper
procedure
i i i was hoping that
they could withdraw the motion so we
could have this
representative spellsbury
thank you mr chairman and perhaps it's
helpful
if i read from my own written notes of
the testimony that
carolyn lear provided at our hearing
uh on january 28th thank you that is
she specifically stated vacation
packages
including ski passes and add-ons only
the room charges are taxed under the
maintenance
under the meals and rooms tax
so that i don't i don't think that's an
open issue
fine so that puts that question to bed
especially if it's separately stated
it's not taxable
representative
you're muted sorry right i noticed that
representative spillsbury had his hand
up um oh but you just talked
sorry uh i just uh one thing that i
forgot to address
was duro when they came in last year
we uh we established
that they are providing the insurance
they are providing i believe
uh uh cleaning if necessary if there's
been
been damage done to the car by the
person that is is
uh loaning it there are a number of
other things that i cannot remember at
this point that they do provide they are
not
just a bulletin board they are making it
possible for
a person that will let their car go to a
stranger feel comfortable
letting the car go to a stranger
any sort of comments or questions
thank you mr chair and i just want to
thank representative almi
representative abrami and you mr chair
for your hard work
on this bill and i already have a motion
uh that i made though seconded by
representative nunes so i would just
like to request that we vote
on my motion about to pass hb 15. thank
you mr chair
any further discussion on the motion
about the past
11th amendment
what's in early
uh thank you mr chair um whoever writes
the blurb should probably
incorporate the uh statement i think uh
representative
spillsbury just said so that uh the
people on the floor have a good idea as
to what this bill does
and doesn't do may i make that
suggestion sir
that's a good thing
thank you um so i believe where we're at
just
double checking actually because we've
had a lot of uh intervening things
we're we're now at on the motion
ought to pass as amended is that right
yes
okay um yes i'm going to vote for this
uh what to pass as amended um
i do so with reluctance because i think
the bill has been diminished
made uh vulnerable to uh
being sidetracked by litigation and uh
i regret that but i think it's a a very
good bill
that uh it levels the playing field in a
way that's
uh been needed for several years that
became
evident through litigation brought uh
several years ago by
one of the uh i think room facilitator
groups that uh
that said that dra was overreaching so
this is a good bill um it's a good bill
with the amendment it could be much
better if we
if we hadn't added this language to the
amendment
thank you thank you for
commenting representative ames any
further
representative romney
i will be voting for the bill obviously
but you know i got a call from the lobby
one of the lobby firms um
the the firm that sean thomas went to
from the dra who actually wrote the
language last year
and sean doesn't know why why that this
amendment is needed either
but uh i tried to explain and uh
you know i just wanted to pass that
along that uh sean thomas who who
who wrote basically wrote the language
in the subcommittee with us that worked
on this
but uh but we'll vote for it as is with
the amendment
um and let's let's let's move this
forward
any further comments
once more any further comments on house
bill 15 as amended
saying then i'll ask clark to call the
vote
thank you mr chair this is a roll call
vote on hb
15 fn the motion is ought to pass
with amendment begin the roll call vote
with representative abrami
yes representative troy marner
yes representative orwery
yes representative over
no
the clerk votes yes representative
doucet
representative ducette good now fred
you're good yes
thank you representative elliott
you're muted representative yes thank
you sir
representative genidion yes
representative nunes yes representative
baxter
yes representative spillsbury
yes representative tudor
yes representative only
yes representative ames
yes representative
yes representative malloy
yes representative schamberg
no representative tucker
yes representative gomarlo
yeah laughman
yes representative gorg
yes
thank you representative hacken phillips
representative murphy yes
chairman major yes yes
mr chair the vote is 22 in the
affirmative
two voted against the motion and the
amendment carries
the vote been 22 in favor and two
against
the motion of what to pass with
amendment
we'll go on the regular calendar and
[Music]
mr chair representative schamberg here
you'll
providing a minority report right yes i
will provide the minority report
am i to send an attachment to you or to
the court or whatever you send the
minority report to me
and majority report also
i'm sorry what was that the majority and
minority report
oh okay thank you sir and when when do
you want that
well today is thursday
monday yes sir thank you
all right that closes our business
on the executive session
all right now we will
change and just go
into a discussion of the
parts of hospital ii that affects
the revenues
i'll given a um
a document that jennifer put together
for us where she went to
the entire hospital too and pulled out
those sections which she felt had some
relations
with revenues that were in house built
too
and the first part the first item
is before establishing the graphic
service fund in the department of
administrative services
section four page two
appears to establish a new dedicated
fund that is not
labeled as such
have you had a chance to look at that
and i'm going to pull up house built two
separately on another
computer because i don't have a copy of
it
they've mailed me a copy but i don't i
haven't received it yet
he representative
uh mr chairman on i found i think it's
about
10 other cases in which
they'd set up dedicated funds that
that on are not treated as dedicated
funds
okay it may not be that many i've got to
go back and count
but there are there are a fair number of
them
um and this one
this one i believe a number of these
only need a 612.
this that's that's on in
612 all the dedicated funds uh
rsa 612 all the dedicated funds are
supposed to be
uh established and the only uh
difference is on in some cases within
dedicated funds they use
accounting units only
rather than listing things
which could include this i guess
arguably as
uh on a
a on accounting unit but not as
a dedicated subfund within
on das but i don't believe das has a
dedicated fund that it would be a sub
fund of it's a revolving account
on and it off so that
that monies that come in for for
on graphics services get separated off
from everything else in das
and can't get transferred to them easily
i don't see anything associated with
these graphic
services dedicated funds that wouldn't
pack the revenues that we
need
so we're not going to deal at all with
the dedicated funds issues because when
they put
on that is one of our charges as the
ways and means committee
and they put uh when they put something
in without that we have to go back and
mop it up the next
year so we will discuss this
when we go into dedicated funds i don't
see anything here that's kind of
there's nothing about revenues
sequesterings the next item is
number 24 suspend revenue sharing norm
christie has his hand up he may be able
to shed some light
okay chris go ahead
uh thank you represent major
so just just to give the committee a
little background on the graphic
services
in the budget that's treated as a
restricted fund so the revenue they
collect
goes directly to graphic services and at
the end of the fiscal year
if there's any money left it
transfers to the general fund if there's
a negative the general fund helps pay
for
any shortfall so typically um
surpluses have ranged anywhere from
thirteen thousand to sixty thousand
dollars
in fiscal year twenty there was a 140
shortfall in revenue due to the pandemic
so the department um is requesting to
set up a dedicated fund
um that clearly defines um you know that
this
graphic services can keep the money in
the fund so when they do have a
year where they're short revenue they
can go into the fund and bring the money
forward
there's also some concerns about some
long-term employees within
that division or group that will be
retiring
and they wanted to um in the next few
years and they were hoping to kind of
build up a reserve to
um help with the payout that would be
associated with a person leaving state
service
instead of having to go to a salary and
benefit adjustment account which has
been um
diminishing over the years based on the
better
budgeting that occurs with positions
so i just want to give the committee
that you know that that is what's going
on with graphic services
and it does establish a dedicated fund
um
in section 7 of house bill 2 was
introduced
in 612. just to be clear there as well
section 7 and yeah it creates the
graphics services fund and it inserts it
into 612
following um subparagraph 364.
so this section number that's associated
with this
it should have been section seven rather
than section well
well that's the that's where the funds
created i think the sections you have
um earlier kind of describe the what's
going on with graphic services
that just to hopefully help you know
clarify anything
are there a lot of 612's in section
seven
i didn't see section seven is that just
graphic services yes it's specific to
graphic services
i would need to look at some of the
others represent all me to see um
why they didn't it didn't include the
612 why they didn't there may be a
reason
right section 7's
strictly profit services fund
all right the um
none of us have a copy of hb2 i think
i just pulled it up on my laptop so
um the next section the number
is just revenue sharing with cities in
town for the biennium
norm there's more questions
uh representative ober
thank you mr chairman um i've only been
in the house for 20 years but i'm a
little lost here
what is the objective what are we doing
here
talking about house bill 2 which is a
finance bill
i understand the requirements we have
but
what what are we supposed to get out of
this discussion today
the finances asked us to look at house
bill 2
and pick out all those things associated
with revenue
and give their estimate and give an
estimate to them
whether it's going to be positive or
negative
so we've been asked by finance to do
this
they gave us about a half a dozen places
to look at
i asked jennifer to go through the whole
house bill
too and there are other issues that
could possibly affect
revenues and that's what we're doing
today
i understand thank you
representative bromley yeah then so
as far as this one is concerned it
creates a new fund
but it doesn't create revenue or destroy
revenue it just moves revenue around to
a different fund is that correct
uh maybe chris shea could respond to
that right it doesn't create revenue
and is it is it is it that different
departments
to pay in for use of this graphic
service bureau exactly the internal
so all the um a lot of materials that um
you get if you're on a fiscal committee
right now
are coming from graphic services we're
using them to do mass
production and we pay them for that
service as do
other agencies that use graphic services
um
it comes out of your budget your impact
on your general fund could be anywhere
from ten to
sixty thousand dollars a year because
you would now have that restricted
um de minimis in the amount i mean it
would be in the other fun
category to begin with um you wouldn't
see it you wouldn't know it
um and and the reason for again
establishing the dedicated account
or fund um was to build up a little bit
of a reserve in in the funds so that
they could address
um some anticip anticipated retirements
coming up but as well as when there's um
times when agencies as we are
experiencing with the pandemic aren't
using graphic services
as much because people aren't producing
paper
um the same way they might have in the
past because of everything being sent
electronically
graphic services doesn't have enough
revenue to in 20 at least in 2020 didn't
have enough revenue
to cover it expense expenditures so the
general fund has had to cover that for
them
so again i think this was just an effort
on their part to put some money in a
dedicated fund and use it for graphic
services over the long period not the
short term
okay represented yearly followed by
representative elliott
thank you mr chair i was just concerned
about setting up yet another
dedicated fund that we're going to have
to monitor well the idea of setting
money aside
in a fund uh seems to make sense and it
seems to me uh
fiscally sound um is this going to wind
up with one of those other funds that
you and representative almi are going to
have to uh
look at and look at to see whether or
not it's being used or
is going to wind up you know someplace
in the garbage heap where
no one does anything with it because the
money
for what's being done is now just
languishing in an account somewhere
let me clear something up here
our purpose right now is to identify
those parts of house bill
2 that will affect revenues
that will go to the general fund or the
highway fund or efficient game fund
we came upon this this is the first item
has to do
with a dedicated fund being sent out
we looked at it and it doesn't affect it
doesn't seem like it's going to affect
the
revenues going to the fund so
we will save any further discussion on
that
with the dedicated fund committee
so then we can move on to section 42
which is the next one that's been
identified by jennifer and
thanks thanks pat for keeping me honest
here
you're muted yes i spent a lot of time
yesterday
um trying to get a copy of house bill
2 and when my computer was done i
realized that i got
the wrong year in there i had 2019
and that was 160 pages long
so then i tried 2021
and i was told that there is no report
yet
so i'm assuming that i should have used
the year
2020. is that correct
no i'm looking at the house built too
that just came out on the
site when you say it just came out
you talking about today or yesterday
it's been out a few days
uh is there a date on honesty
it's a 2021 session
good morning
well maybe there's something wrong with
my computer because it says
uh yesterday it said that it hasn't been
written yet
so i'll try again with 2021
send getting a copy
which i assume will be another 160 pages
long
representative obama was shaking his
head no
what did do you mind if i asked him why
well yeah because jennifer four
summarized for us
the sections of house bill 2 that were
relevant and that's that's what i'm
working off of here
i just resent it to representative
elliot because i headed up
and so she sent you a summary
well thank you we're not touching all of
the hospital too just some sections
your legislative be male is that okay is
that
correct no don't send it to send it to
334 north broadway
salem new hampshire i emailed it
oh okay it's only about it's only about
seven or eight pages long oh okay that's
that's a blessing
160 pages okay thank you jenny
okay on to the second piece
of the many pieces uh
has to do with suspending revenue
sharing with cities and towns for the
biennium
uh that's strictly up to the finance
committee to make that
all we can do is come up and we will be
what is the total amount of revenue
the rooms and meals tax is going to be
raising
in fy 22 and 23
and 21 and
there's a certain percentage by law that
should go back
to the towns as as long as the
legislator doesn't suspend it in which
they've been
doing it and just sending a portion of
the
future
i just add that this
provision is exactly the same as the
provision two years ago in the previous
budget
yeah exactly and
this one here the finance committee's
gonna have to make up the decision what
they want to do once
we finalize what the revenues are going
to be
in the ways and means we gave them our
estimates
when we work on it next week we may
change that depending upon what we find
out
the next one is
enabling the liquor commission to
process merchant cards
and that's section 43.
can we appreciate explain that norm his
hands up
okay uh representative uh yeah
sue i'm sorry we'll hear from chris
first
uh thank you represent major so section
43 the liquor commission processing of
merchant cards
that's been in house bill 2 for at least
three
times now and what that language does it
allows
the liquor commission not to have to go
through doit
when they have an issue with their
computer system that's attached to their
point of service or point of sales
and so they've asked for that each year
each of the budget years i think for the
last three
cycles um because there was some
concerns that doit couldn't be as
responsive as they might need if their
systems went down say on the weekend
i think they have a contractor
on retainers not the right word but
they have somebody that they've agree
are working with to
make sure that they can keep their
credit card system up and running and if
there's any
um issues they can be nimble and quick
to respond and
so in terms of a revenue impact there's
no direct revenue impact related to that
so we can move on you can
next item in section 77
transfer funds from the revenue
stabilization reserve account to the
general
fund surplus and that's strictly a
decision
of the finance committee
and so we should be able to move on
the next is section 78 reduce the tax
rate of and in
2027 and eliminate the interest and
dividend tax
now the way
it's written in the budget it's going to
affect fy23
and fy23
is what is the estimate
uh from the dra
has it changed and what it what did they
provide
yes yeah
uh they did they said uh the impacts
into
fiscal 23 6.3 million reduction
okay um
is the dras on the line can we just ask
him if they still stand behind the 6.3
million
yes let's see who was here
i just promoted carolyn okay good
carolyn
carolyn lear
hi mr chair carolyn lear assistant
commissioner at the new hampshire
department of revenue
i can confirm that the 6.3
million figure is still good for fiscal
year 2023
but if you have any in-depth questions
about that analysis i would ask that you
unmute melissa rollins who actually did
that analysis
any anybody want to
ask melissa rollins on the
analysis she did to get this 6.3
representative thank you on
is that just the uh
estimate payments for
march april and and june
of 23.
why don't we bring melissa in
i gave her permission to speak melissa
did you answer that question
i did uh for the record melissa rollins
senior financial analyst at the
department of revenue
thank you representative elmi for your
question you're spot on
um that is just for those estimate
payments
in april and june um it's about 20
uh it's just a small percentage that
will be applicable about 27
will be applicable for fiscal year 23 so
just a partial impact because of
estimate payments
and if i could then after in the
following budget years
on we will lose 20 percent
of the revenue sequentially every year
until it's gone
um thank you for the question it's a
little bit more each year so when you
get to fiscal year 24
you're now having the remaining
estimates in returns
plus the next year's estimates so when
you get to fiscal year 24
the impact goes to 22.2 million
and then hovers around the 20 million
mark in until you get to the full phase
out
which will be felt in fiscal year 2029
did we get i don't think we got a sheet
that shows
the extension out to fy29
can we get that information when we
meet with you next
before we review next wednesday
yeah i think that would be i think it
will be in hb2 um
once that's fully submitted and um
posted chris can confirm that for us as
well
well we need your estimate whether it's
we need to confirm that's what the
revenues are going to be
those years representative this is
carolyn lear
again i think what melissa was trying to
say is um
that that will be in the fiscal note for
hb2
um and that we have not given that
to chris it probably will be given to
him today
so as long as the fiscal note is to you
by
wednesday um you should have it but i
don't know that we know
how long it will take them to turn that
around thank you
thank you mr chair can i have a phone
on this on
well this is based on i believe on uh
what we got in
uh when in
fy 2419
on and of course we won't
know what the future is going to bring
that could provide for this tax
but i just want to say that this is
we have never before a few terms ago
tried to put multi-year taxes that are
only
affecting future budgets not the budget
we're in
on into the budget bill
which cannot be properly
vetted and and argued because it's part
of the budget
and on i believe that this
is fiscally irresponsible that we are
committing
the state on to
losing a very large amount of money
at some point in the future we have no
idea which
what the state is going to need at that
point
thank
um i want to first
second what uh representative omni just
said but
i want to uh emphasize sort of a
a piece of that
that this conversation points towards
we're talking about
revenue losses in the years after the
this two-year budget and i think
we need to when we have a proposed piece
of legislation like this
that reaches beyond the budget period
and that's good that we're doing that
but i think
as a general principle we need to
it's one of our responsibilities to
document
what those impacts are in the years
after after the in this case fiscal year
23.
um and so here in in the case of this
tax it's very clear there are
significant impacts
i'd like to see those clearly laid out i
i believe that's what
dra is going to be doing for us we're
going to be looking at other sections of
hp2
that also have similar uh
that relate forward and have impact and
we need to
put it all together and show to what
extent
we're diminishing or maybe in some cases
increasing the flow of revenue into the
general fund and education trust fund
i completely agree with both years and
represents comments
but we have to
live with what we have right right now
is
to me that's not the right way to do it
but
we need to address it
further comment on section 78
which has to do with a reduction in the
interest and dividend tax
then we'll move on to mr mr chairman
yes if i could i also think that this
particular way of doing it reducing by
percentage
on puts the advantage
to the richest people up front
the way that it was being done in the
bill that was put in
it increased the deductions every
uh each year
which took away part of the tax each
year it took away
less of it in the beginning but it also
helped enormously the people who have
the most trouble
paying it from the beginning and this
one does not
thank you what would your recommendation
be
well to eliminate it all together but
but faulting that to to use the
deduction
method which
at least helps the people who who
have the most trouble paying and would
you say
there's a reduction method that
generates the same amount of
reduction i believe that it would not
generate as much reduction from the
beginning
because the people that would be
i'm not sure we we need the drh to take
a look at it
why don't we do that and uh
see what that looks like okay
uh perhaps and news thank you mr
chairman uh and uh in this discussion
are we talking about the bill that came
through
that that uh raised the exemption
is that what we're saying that that
we're that we would like to be more
familiar with that bill instead of
what's going on here
yes we retained that bill to do that
but just some of the language that was
on there was that we were saying
deduction and i just wanted to clarify
that we were talking about the bill with
the exemptions with the with the raised
exemption
yes thank you it's just clarification
thank you
anything else on the interest and
dividend tax
norm yeah representative bromley yeah i
mean it's the two bills the one was
lying's bill
and uh he he also had the uh
the uh the tax credit reversal
uh but that's that was the minimum bill
the other the other bill
[Music]
was the was the big bill that actually
got got rid of it in five years got rid
of this tax in five years
uh i think that's the bill that also but
they also increased the
exemptions as it went along hp58
yeah so look i i think i think for now
we do we're trying to estimate what the
impact of the governor's position is for
finance of the of the two of the
next two years uh which we're doing
but if we if as a committee
we think that another approach
you know we can insert what uh
one of the other bills and try to
convince finance to uh
to to insert it into hp2 instead
but that's just that's the only option
really that or just vote against the
budget
so put your thinking cap on review those
two bills
and relative to what the governor is
proposing
and see if you can come up with what you
think it might be a better way
with the understanding that many members
that don't want to do don't want this
reduction at all
even some republicans by the way so
um not to this extent but that's
another discussion it's not going to be
easy
right rather than an army yes i think
that we need the dras comparison of
how much how much loss each time
in order to discuss that yes
this is our first blush and
put these questions out on the table
what do we need to do
all right we go to the next
session section which is section 90
oh hold yeah
section 92 through 94
reduced the tax rate on the meals and
rooms tax
and this is reducing it from
nine percent to eight and a half percent
the mills and rooms tax and
chris what is that
what does the governor have for reducing
it
a half a percent
chris shelly are you still there yeah
i'm still with you sorry
it's 19 million dollars um
in 22 and in 23.
and that came from the dra my
understanding
we all have these numbers by the way
this when we were doing the comparison
of the governor's
revenues these are the adjustments made
for his
his new tax uh reduction comment on that
chair major yes um
i don't have that she that uh
representative abrami just spoke to
right in front of me
somewhere in these this mess here uh but
um
what i remember is that the uh
there was an increase in this revised
document from the governor of the
expected amount to be collected from the
rooms of meals tax
um total for this year
and but then the
[Music]
that increase it seemed to me should
have left
led to a greater loss
in the next two years because now we're
working off of a higher
amount and with the drop in the
percentage and the tax
it essentially means you lose more uh
it's only two or three or four million
dollars but it's something
so um maybe that's a question to dra
chris did you get that i think this
really important
you're right but i heard what
represented ames said and and i would
defer to dra but
i think part of the issue is that um
there's been no adjustments because the
governor introduced a
revenue as part of his budget proposal
since then he's come out with a letter
um where he's adjusted some of his
assumptions related to the to the
revenue but we don't have uh
we don't have any other adjustments at
this point
but again i would defer to dra to to see
how they
are handling that if at all at this
point
in the governor's letter a lot of that
has to do with the results in february
the results in february total
is close to it's up about
18 or 19 but
one of the things we want to remember
was that 10 million of that is one-time
money
due to the lottery the powerball and
the other one coming in which doesn't
happen every year
so that's a one-time event and the other
one is
is the tax um
audit of
extra 10 million dollars in february
that normally
never comes in february that's according
to the
um the ira that that's normally
so when you add those two together 20
million dollars
and so to you subtract that from the
february
results you're going to be under
the plan rather than over the plan by
18.7 million
the governor in his letter indicates
that because of february's results
being so high compared to the plan
there's a lot of shifting going on so
we've got to look at that closely
so the what we made from the vras
is that is the 19 million dollar
reduction
in 22 and 23 is what we know
now about maybe the reopening
and the economy uh
these numbers change
by march 17th or 18th
so anything more on the males and realms
tax
the next is section 95-97
thank you on the only result
of this tax reduction would be that
we're losing 19 million dollars a year
plus
maybe something um
because people do not
pay attention to the tax on their bills
and if they did
they would realize that they're going to
get an extra five cents
uh back
on on a ten dollar i think it's on a ten
dollar
uh purchase and um
they just aren't going to react to that
on it just seems like an unnecessary
thing to do it would be better to put
that kind of money into something that's
going to
help the owners of the restaurants
which i think the senate has been
working on
when you're putting a budget together
and you need an extra 20 million dollars
this is one way of getting it many ways
to skin that cat
my understanding is that that slight
rejection
is for large group sales or
weddings or big conventions or things
like that
and you know i just wonder whether we
shouldn't be
asking someone uh in the restaurant
lodging business
whether that is really
where where activity is apt to happen
this is a really significant amount of
money
um and i'm just bewildered
as to whether the that's really how this
that industry works
it'll be very hard to get it back
in the future
representative thank you mr chairman
you know this i have to agree with
representative all me
about you know the impact this has on
the consumer and whether or not it makes
them
choose our businesses versus an
alternative simply because of this tax
reduction i
i highly skeptical that it makes any
difference other than it will reduce our
revenues you know and every
this is a high performing tax revenue
source for the state
and every dollar we raise from out of
state tourists
with this tax revenue stream is a dollar
that we don't have to raise through
property taxes or some other means
i just think that the net effect of
reducing
this tax rate is going to be a
reduction in state revenue
[Music]
really no difference in the kind of
consumer activity
in this area and perhaps a downshifting
of costs because the state will be
less able to assist municipalities
because of the reduction in funds i
think this is
it sells well politically saying we're
going to reduce this rate i think it's
bad for the state
[Music]
and i'm sorry to see it happening
representative germano
you mr chair i just wanted to add that
the amount of work that both businesses
and dra
have to do to change the rate
a half a percent
is not worth the effort
i mean it's just a yeah just wanted to
put that piece in there
you have to change your computer system
to accommodate the change in the rate
and yeah so it's a little change
generates 20 million bucks a year no
and that's my feeling is that's the way
they see it
that's the money is
whatever representative
you have your hands up again
yes thank you i just wanted to point out
at this point
section 65 on page 26
the governor has suspended the funding
of travel and tourism development
for the biennium now
that was installed when we put
the rooms and meals tax up to nine
percent during the great recession
to help us get through the great
recession and
it was a trade-off for for
the tourism and on travel
on lounging and restaurant association
that they appreciated what it does
is it provides advertising large-scale
advertising to whatever markets they
think
are going to be most important for new
hampshire
on to to provide the image of new
and provide the idea that you want to go
to new hampshire for your vacations
and ever since we put that in
with a little dip when they took it out
for one term
on they uh we have had five
percent per year growth in
travel and tourism in uh rooms and meals
taxes
particularly in specific and so
it has more than paid for itself and it
has helped
all of the smaller businesses the big
chains
and the really big places like mount
washington hotel can do their own
advertising
the rest of them can't and this is what
has been helping increase the
the tourism inside of new hampshire and
it's being suspended for two years
no matter if we like the policy that's
in house built too our job today
is to evaluate the changes
that would affect and this change does
affect revenues
it's going to we're coming back from the
great
from the the a major recession
and from people being stuck in their
houses forever and wanting to travel
if new hampshire is not in advertising
in front of them
they're going to choose to go other
places and every other state knows that
so section 55 we're talking about
65 65.
it's on page 26.
you know what the latest issue of house
bill 2
on page 26 covers
56 57 58.
so you said it's section 65.
it suits in your humidity
your muted scissors
sorry i i can't unmute while i'm trying
to look at it look it up
on it's called suspension of the funding
of travel and tourism development
on i've got it down as as
26 but i can't look at it at the same
time that we're meeting
okay so it's section 60 something right
65.
or if you search for travel and tourism
i'm going to try and go back and
look at that again
my section 65 has to do with office of
professional licenses
good grief how did that oops oh dear
major this is chris it's section 55 of
house build
it's located on page 26. thank you
if you're looking at a pdf it's page 31
of the pdf but it's listed as page 26 of
hb2
correct thank you representative
berstein i do that all the time
yeah here it is i got the page right but
i managed to uh i'm getting cataracts
and it's getting harder to see
so it's just three lines on page
31 of the pdf and page 26 of the other
one
okay
but that costs considerably less than
the 20 million if i remember correctly
it's around six or eight million
that they've that has been going into
that advertising
and the idea that they're taking it out
just at the time
when people are going to be making
decisions to
go places is difficult
so taking that out how much is it going
to affect the revenue
you will want to look at what the effect
will be
plymouth state university keeps on doing
studies that show it's eight dollars for
every one dollar we spend
on and the of the eight dollars
on we get
back
so maybe you could
continue looking at that
yes um i'm gonna have to go back and
find the plymouth state stuff i think it
was
eight dollars in taxes that we were
getting back for every one dollar we
spent on it
so you're gonna we're going to look at
that section and yeah
and bring the committee up to date when
we meet on
wednesday next week right i will i will
we'll find the people that are doing
that
okay the next section has to do with
section 95 to 97.
um before we move on then norm can i ask
a question
yes represent um
chris what is going to be the
money effect i mean how much money is it
that would
we're not going to be losing and i'd
like to see that number
uh i know it's a static number and all
that stuff but
basically in relation to what reps of
already to what was just being discussed
in the travel and tourism that
that um
so just so the committee knows the
finance committee is working
on this section right now we're trying
to figure out
why it was suspended in house bill 2.
it may have been suspended because based
on the calculation
maybe they would have gotten less money
than they typically got
in past years but we're trying to we're
we're looking to find out how that was
calculated
um what the number would have been
compared to what put in the budget
um we're having some challenges getting
that information
um but once i get something i can share
it back with you
um as to what what the number would be
as well as what was put in the budget
and maybe why they did this suspension
in prior budgets they suspend it because
the
uh the committee has made decisions that
they want to just appropriation on the
um on the department related to travel
and tourism and not abide by this but i
don't know if that's the case
in this instance so i'll have to get
back to your reps and vulnerabilities
already just a long way of saying that
yeah
yeah well thank you and just because the
the argument or the discussion that
susan put forward is compelling
it's been compelling for about over a
decade now
thank you
okay uh representative lockman seems to
have his hand up
i do uh thank you mr chairman i
i was briefly disconnected so i'm not
sure if it was touched on but i i did
hear
before i lost my connection wondering
what the effect was and i wonder if
you know our
tourism leadership there could comment
on the return on investment of money
spent
in advertising because that would seem
to
illuminate how much return we're losing
out on by investing nothing
you know if in past years when we do put
money in
the expected return on that investment
is x then
then that increased uh tourism activity
is what we're losing out on by investing
nothing so i don't know maybe that's the
number we could get
okay representative alami is going to be
pursuing
along with chris
yeah i think chris will be pursuing with
the department and i can pursue the
plymouth state university studies
they've done them on every few years
we should have more information when we
meet next wednesday
okay the next item is section 95 to 97
to increase the filing threshold for the
business enterprise tax
and the last thing we received from the
uh the ira was
it would increase have a decrease of 2.3
million in each year
that's still a good number
but that number's changed now norm
and maybe uh i think the dra can explain
their new numbers of course
but again i think the dra would be the
more appropriate
but yeah what i have is
yeah it doesn't change for 22 but it
goes
from 2.3 to 3.1 for
20 20. but but on the original sheet
that we worked on a couple of
like a month ago whatever it was it was
2.3 and 2.3
and dra has now changed it to 0 and 3.1
uh 3.1 loss of revenue
so they may want to explain uh the
reason why they changed from their
original
caroline
yes representative major this is melissa
rollins again um
so yes happy to explain this so i
believe
representative abrami what you're
speaking to is
um a proposal that was originally
received
by the governor's office from the dra
this had a little bit different
parameters than what came through in hb2
which is what changes
um the amount of the fiscal impact so i
think what you have in front of you
was a proposal just based on changing
the business um the
one of the business enterprise
thresholds versus changing
both of the thresholds and in hb2 it
changes
um the gross receipt threshold from 220
thousand to two hundred and fifty
thousand and then
the um the enterprise value threshold
from 220 or excuse me from one hundred
and eleven thousand to two hundred and
fifty thousand so with the business
enterprise tax there are two
thresholds and hb2 changes both of those
thresholds
which is what the increase is so we have
a fiscal impact
of 3.1 million for
um fiscal year 23
um and no impact in in 22
and this is because there might be a
slight impact in fiscal year 22 because
of estimates but it was
minor um a minor impact because the
reduction is so
low that we just put the full impact in
fiscal year 23.
okay and that's not going to change
correct
okay any further questions i'll ask
melissa yeah i have a question
um representative going forward after
fiscal year 23 is the number any
different
it is not that that's the full impact
okay
i have a question also
what how many people uh
how many businesses will cease to
file sure great
great question representative elmi um
so i'm going to give two data points
here just because i think they're both
um they both have some good information
uh so the amount of people that will or
taxpayers that will potentially not file
and there's a caveat to this so i'll say
that afterwards
is 34 780
that's based on tax year 18 um
return data which is our last completed
year
however of those 34 780 taxpayers
only 5027 of them had
a liability so a lot of taxpayers are
filing zero returns and not paying
because they potentially meet the
threshold but don't
have a tax liability what i do want to
say
in my caveat is gross receipts is a
little bit difficult to
um to calculate on only because
not all taxpayers report their gross
receipts it's a line that is on the
business enterprise tax return
however it is not a line that calculates
into
um a tax liability so we do have a lot
of taxpayers that put
zero on there so we just assume they
wouldn't need to file
however they may need to file so that
thirty four thousand seven hundred and
eighty no longer filing is a maximum
filing amount there may be
um it may be a reduced number
melissa what was that number 5000 and
what
5027 are the taxpayers that will no
longer be
filing the business enterprise tax who
currently had a liability
in tax year 18.
any further questions for melissa
all right mr chairman
just a foul
so oh so so it's only 5 000
out of how many approximately are filing
um are paying now
would you like the total number number
of bet filers
as a whole well no that pay
i'm thinking about the lawsuit we once
had in which
on on the business enterprise tax was
created because
uh the big businesses were saying they
were paying the business
tax and nobody else was
so i always want to make sure that we've
got enough people
paying the ladder so that the former
doesn't get attacked again
sure if you give me one second
so there are and i'm basing this on
our triangles that are in our annual
report
there are around 38 000
that are paying so of the 38 000 5000
will no longer be required
um to file and pay based on the
threshold increase
but just intuitively that sounds safe
it would be about 34 000 pounds left
further questions for melissa
all right then we will move on
section 98 to 99
reduce the rate of the tax for the
business enterprise tax
from 0.6
to 0.55
and then initially
that showed that they reduced the
revenues fy twenty to
four point seven million dollars fy
23 13.3 are those numbers still good
melissa uh yes representative major
those numbers are still accurate
norman then there's the offsetting uh
bpt revenue increase that they
also estimated melissa may want to
explain that
the offsetting bpt revenues for 22
would be an increase of 2.8 and
8.1 and melissa go ahead and explain
that
sure so i think most of you are pretty
familiar with our
rate reduction analysis knowing that
it's on a static analysis
this one is a little bit different
because
we're just reducing the bet rate
typically the rate reductions go hand in
hand with bet
and bpt together so we don't have to
account for what we had to account for
with this fiscal note which is the bet
credit so for the newer members when you
have
a bpt liability you can offset that
liability by
the bet paid that's a credit
against your bpt and then you pay the
net difference
so what we needed to look at because the
bet
rate is being reduced the bet liability
is being reduced meaning the bet credit
to offset the bpt
is then reduced hopefully i haven't lost
anybody yet
um so looking at we had to look at
what would the bpt impact be
if there was a credit that was reduced
so
less money on file to reduce that bpt
liability
based on less back credit on file
so we looked at taxpayers whose bpt
taxpayers who have a bet credit on file
against their bpt liability
and what would they have paid in tax
year 18
if that bet credit was reduced
by the new rate so essentially what
their bp their bet liability would
look like as a bet credit at the new
rate because it would be less
so looking at that reduced bet credit
increases the bpt
and that increase flows through to the
2.8
impact in fiscal year 22 and the 8.1
additional revenue in fiscal year 23.
and would you explain why it's not a one
for one
um it's not a one for one because not
all taxpayers
not all taxpayers bet
exceeds their bpt so some taxpayers just
file
bet and they don't the bet credit
um is not going to reduce their bpt so
that those taxpayers were taken out of
the pool because they have no bpt
liability
to be increased because of a less credit
so
those people came out and also people
whose
bet credit uh exceeds their bpt
liability
those people are removed as well because
the bet credit um
is already greater than the bpt
liability so they're not paying bpt
again
that works out to be about 60
61 you're correct
on what was what were the numbers for
the
bet going down
a number of us don't have these ages
oh sure so to us sure the
back credit uh the bet rate reduction
would be a four point
um i'm going to round 4.7
million loss in 22
and in 23 it's a 13.3 million dollar
loss
for the bet credit and then i'll just
repeat that's then
offset by the bpt increase in fiscal
year 22
of 2.8 million
and in fiscal year 23 the bpd increase
of
8.1 million
so the net impact if you'd like that
for fiscal year 22 for the rate
reduction so that's the bet
decrease minus the bbt increase is 1.8
million
in 22. 5.2 million
in fiscal year 23.
in just in anticipation of
representative ames's question
this does flow through to fiscal year 24
as
well
okay further questions of melissa
saying none we can move on
next is sections 102-105
which limits the amount of credit
allowed against overpayment
of the business profits tax and the
business enterprise tax
we hear from the dra how this works
uh melissa would you want to
explain this
sure um so this one is a is a new fiscal
impact i don't believe you guys have
seen so just to take a step back i know
uh most of the committee is familiar
with the credit carryover concept but
i'll i'll explain that real quick just
as
as a base knowledge so a credit
carryover
is when a taxpayer overpays their
tax liability and has extra funds on
file that they can either receive
as a refund or a credit
to carry over to the next year's
liability
so in this scenario this is looking at
that credit that they're carrying over
to the next year liability
next year's liability
so looking at the bill this credit is
trying to reduce that outstanding credit
that's sitting on file
um by 50 of the taxpayers prior
liability
so there is about for tax year looking
at tax year
2018 um
it's about 279.7 million dollars in
credit care reverse sitting on file
how much uh 279.7
keeps growing um it does keep growing
sitting on file to be utilized to offset
future tax liabilities for taxpayers and
taxpayers
do use this in different ways by either
reducing some of their estimate payments
some taxpayers
some taxpayers keep it on file as a
safety net
and there's there's other options as why
they have it on there so what hb2
is doing is saying it wants to limit
that credit carry over on file to 50
of the tax the taxpayers tax liability
so it wouldn't let taxpayers carry more
than 50 percent of their liability
forward each year would that mean that
it automatically get a refund yes
okay that's correct and
what do you anticipate that buildup is
going
uh or this law is going to do to that
buildup
where it's built up to 279 where this
law goes in
is it going to be less
yeah so i think the purpose of this is
is to make that
credit sitting on file much less than
what it is
today um that would be like a one-time
event really
because then let's say they have to
refund 50 million dollars
that's going to be a hit to total
revenues see your right representative
major it is
um it is a a hit to the revenues
however it could be spread out based on
how taxpayers
uh how taxpayers use this
outstanding credit because they could
instead of waiting for a refund
at the end of the fiscal year they could
just not make estimate payments
and have the estimate payments eat up
that
uh credit carryover on file do you have
any idea
what this
what the level would be once this law
goes into effect
we do um we have tried to analyze it
so i do want to um there's ranges
because it's hard to determine
having never uh implemented a lot like
this it's hard to determine what exactly
the fiscal impact will be
so i can give you the range for each
fiscal year
and tell you what the maximum fiscal
impact would be at the end
we can be pleased or scared like heck
so would you like me to give you the
ranges that would be
good how many ranges do you have
um i have a range for each fiscal year
from 22
to 25 or i can just give you the full
fiscal impact you tell me what's easier
to digest
well there's only three sets of ranges
why don't you get
okay so for fiscal year 22
this would be a scenario where they
either don't adjust their
estimates or they do adjust their
estimate so it would be between if they
don't adjust their estimates
it would be zero to 30.2 million
okay
um then 23
and 23 it would be
between 4.9 and 84.5
wow okay and 24. in 24
it would be 20.6 to 107 million
and this would be the excess
yes that's correct that would have to be
refunded
wow who thought this was a good idea
that's my reaction why would we want to
give the money back
i've always been scared of this it looks
like
we're forcing ourselves for this thing
to happen
we're shooting ourselves in the foot but
that's okay
okay is there one more year
there is and then in 25 it's zero to
25.4 million
okay so now the hump is over yeah so the
total fiscal impact depending on how
taxpayers adjust within there would not
exceed 137.3 million
and and i do want to note we are still
working on the fiscal note for this
piece so
um this is this is our estimate as of
today
wow
who came up with this
representative major this is assistant
commissioner carolyn lear i think this
is
um a natural extension of some of the
conversations that the state has been
required to have
um over the last few years about booking
a liability relative to outstanding ccos
i i agreed to get this down but wow
i was always afraid once it's going to
happen this
i fall at least
you're not talking about 200 million
dollars in one black
all right mr chairman yes
but i i still don't understand exactly
what we're doing
on are we talking about the entire
credit that they already have backed up
or are we talking about the credit which
i thought we were talking about
the credit that they uh acquire in a
single year
representative only this is carolyn
again this would
impact credits that are on file today
and it would also prevent the additional
accumulation of
credits going forward so it would be
both
so if
so so if you had on um
five million dollars on file there
uh you would have to to
get 2.5 of it back in a refund in the
single year
is that
depending on your
last year's liability yes um so if their
last year's liability was five million
and they have a five million dollar
credit on file
then yes they would have to receive a
2.5
million dollar refund um the department
would not allow them to continue to
carry
that full 5 million dollar credit on
their taxpayer account
could we spread this out over 10 years
or something
that's a good question representative i
think that there are
absolutely options that we could um
discuss with the committee um to
ease into the fiscal impact if that's
something that you would
like to see from us
well i i think i'd like to see those
numbers
because they're talking in 23 and 24
those
could end up being a horrible hits
right and 24 could be as much as
getting rid of the interest and dividend
tax
in one year
all right but could we
also consider on
two statements one for what they're
getting
having credit this year and a different
percentage required to take off from
past
representatives this is carolyn again i
think the
the difficulty with that is that um
if not statutorily at least in our
administrative rules
we always account for the oldest
money first so and that's you know
consistent with generally accepted
accounting principles so the cco
that's on their account is always or
almost always
new it's only for the very very
largest dollar values of ccos that you
could
that would save you anything um
because we're always using the taxpayers
old money first to pay their liability
i miss a chair there are a number of
people with hands up i just opened mine
up and i noticed that nice
i go there i should be at the back of
the line i was just going to
go there and so that the first one
as here's the order would be a browning
early spillsbury
and yourself so representative
yeah norma i think we've really got to
do something about this one
um i think when we talk to finance
i mean this is going to be quite a hit
in uh
definitely in 23 and 24 but 23s
you know within the the budget year
they're trying to deal with
um wow um
i i think i think we we should we should
we should give him the number as it is
but then say you know there's
maybe we need to modify this hb2
uh line and uh and move this and spread
it out over the
longer period of time but i mean i have
a question for
for carolyn that so you're saying that
the auditors
are who who's telling us to do this the
auditors
oh um no i we weren't i
this was a um was within the governor's
proposal so i think it's fair to say
that if it
comes from the governor's office i don't
believe that the auditors directed us to
do this
um i think it was just a proposed
solution
to what has been an ongoing issue
you know if you don't do this
it could be if the big guys got together
and said
hey we want to refund
on our money right now and there's like
million dollars and and 220 million
from these guys that would be
devastating
but norm anybody can ask for a refund
right now
no one's no one's twisting them their
arms to say to keep that money the
individual companies that are keep
saying keep the money
for whatever reason oh there's a
possibility that this could happen
oh yeah yeah and i've always been afraid
of that
uh let's go on uh representative
europe thank you that
following up with what uh representative
abrami had just said the
language on this needs to be going
forward
and i don't know how we write that
um i don't mind eliminating it it's a
good idea and it should have been
limited
some time ago i mean you know we've
discussed this
year after year after year and
businesses have been just taking this as
a
uh in the bank type of uh
thing for uh or a rainy day fund if you
will
so carolyn
uh if the state were to say what you
have now
is lost money that would open up the
state to a bunch of suits i believe
i mean a lot of suits and all the money
would have to be regurgitated at one
time
um should the wording be going forward
no more shall apply
and any uh credits due will be taken
from the credits already paid
is something like that would that be
more appropriate
um representative
i think because this bill has an
applicability date
um that that is essentially what it does
um it applies to gosh i should have it
right in front of me but i believe it's
taxable periods ending on or after
december 31st 2022 but melissa you can
jump in if i'm misspeaking there
um so it really will only apply
um to credits
that are being carried forward going
forward
um i think the issue that
a representative um almi brought up
is that there's all there's this large
volume of
old credits going forward and
is there some way to prevent the massive
fiscal impact um when the bill takes
effect
and i think the only way to effectively
do that
is to modify the percentage
measuring point that you're using um
because of how we account for credits in
accordance with generally accepted
accounting principles
um every every time a taxpayer files a
return the credit essentially becomes a
new credit
um to follow up on that mr chair
what you're saying then is that this f
unless something like this bill takes
place
the credit is going to continue to
accumulate at least on paper
forever and it will keep multiplying
like
rabbits if uh we're not if we don't put
some sort of limit on it someplace
absent some sort of modification in
taxpayer
behavior i think it is likely
that the credit will at least stay the
same
um for whatever reason we have some
mostly larger taxpayers that carry
large credits on their account
um and for whatever reason they don't
choose to take a refund
and they don't choose to modify down
their estimated tax payments
and as a result that credit just sits
there
um and i don't know that we have any
signal that taxpayers are going to
change that behavior right now
i agree thank you mr chair
representative spells very
followed by representative james
and bernstein thank you mr chairman uh
i think we're all trying to untangle
this because there's
several different perspectives of
looking at the same number
i'm certainly trying to um but there's a
difference between
you know your balance sheet perspective
versus your cash flow perspective
when i look at this i guess i'm
wondering what the treasurer
has to say about the impact on liquidity
if there was suddenly a call in the
amounts at the higher end of the range
for
23.24 but from a budgeting perspective
am i am i correct in thinking that this
is really uh
not a factor it's it's a neutral these
are
effectively prepayments
against future liability but when we
budget
we're not budgeting according to
what people overpay in their estimates
and accumulates we're budgeting based on
the anticipated liability
uh the net actual tax so
if i've got it right i'd like to hear
from the treasurer
but i don't think there's a budget
impact there's a cash flow impact
i do think that question is best posed
to the treasurer
um i will say that we count those
dollars you know those credits that are
sitting on taxpayer accounts
are recognized in revenue in the year
that they're received
even though they will be used to pay a
tax liability
in a later year theoretically
um so i think that is sort of the crux
of the issue
as to why this is a is potentially a
problem
the cco issue is a problem from um
a state annual financial report
situation and is why we've
had to book a liability in the past
to reflect that fact hey chris can you
get the treasurer to
meet with us next wednesday yeah i can
invite her
yep you bring up a good point in
representation this whole thing scares
the heck out of me
well and it's just to make an analogy to
business it sounds like this is being
dealt with
on a cash accounting basis essentially
rather than an accrual basis
right the cash is in the door they'll
spend it
or they could spend it if they want it
represented hey uh
bernstein and ames and software sorry
yeah thank you mr chair basically
everything i had to say has
pretty much been said already this is an
election by the taxpayer
it's really an interest-free loan to the
state um
maybe the reason why it's growing
on a nominal basis so much as we're in a
very low
interest rate environment so the
opportunity cost is pretty low
letting the state take you keep your
money
um it's just the the
the pain that we're going to endure uh
just seems unnecessary
uh by having to refund this money i i
don't know i'll be interested to hear
what the treasurer has to say next week
i really don't have a question uh but
thank you for letting me
ramble roxanne ames
yeah thank you um to a significant
extent
my question was answered by the question
asked by
uh representative spillsbury um
i was gonna put it as but
but i from what carolyn lear just said
the question might my answer to my
rhetorical question
is not the same i was going to say isn't
this really a department of treasury
issue rather than a revenue issue but i
i now i think i understand that
this money that's kept
that's left by the taxpayer that's
essentially what's happening
left by the taxpayer with dra is being
counted as revenue
yes which i think is the crux of the
problem
um it's not you know it's the taxpayers
money that's sitting up there
and somebody else referred to it as a
interest-free loan by the taxpayer to
the state i think
that's what it looks like to me so if
the taxpayer pulls down
some of that money to apply against a
new
tax liability that's
revenue to the state but if the taxpayer
pulls that down into
whatever his own account
[Music]
then it's it's not
it shouldn't be lost revenue to the
state it should be
less money that the department of
treasury has available to
calculate you know what it needs to
calculate in terms of
cash flow um so
it's sort of a quandary where again as
far as i can see
and we're we've got a pattern of
practice
that has been followed by dra for a long
time maybe i'm completely
misunderstanding this by the way i'm no
expert in accounting um uh
and the specter of having so much money
sitting in our account that has been
i don't know how to describe it so much
money sitting there
that uh when it moves uh
in the wrong direction could mess up the
state
is what we're contending with but i
really don't
i really don't understand why this is a
revenue machine
revenue representative southworth
thank you mr chairman we
often get wide ranges at this point when
we're looking at things
i'm just wondering if we look at the
middle of
the dras range the hump might
not seem as terrible but am i correct
that after that hump is passed
things are going to be much more
predictable and we're going to be safe
from the risk that you've been talking
about um chairman major for some time
so is it a little bit like tearing the
bandage off or whatever and
maybe we do want to spread it out longer
but
will it in fact get us to a better place
in the end
caroline representative i think
the ripping the band-aid off analogy is
a good one
i think that um what were you to do this
um it would be a one-time
impact and then going forward
we would simply no longer allow
these significant accumulation of ccos
on file um so in that way
the problem would be permanently solved
thank you represent spillsberry
yes thank you this further discussion
just
prompts in my mind that this is a moving
target we're looking at
and uh it would be interesting to see
what this figure has been
you know maybe over a monthly basis for
the last three years
and i'm just wondering several things
that that might answer
like we've seen a surge of uh
business uh tax revenues uh
over uh the estimates for this past year
and is that in part due to uh an
escalation of prepayments
or or is it truly that business
taxes are generating more revenue
what's the net
this has been growing every year
over quite a few years um
as far as far as growth goes as far as
the rest of your question
uh carolyn
um actually i'm hoping melissa will
answer this question because she
performs this calculation um i do think
it definitely the number fluctuates so
perhaps she could give um
a more detailed answer than i could but
if not
tell me so melissa no thank you carolyn
um we do report this in our in the tax
expenditure report
every year on a fiscal year basis for
those of you
interested um i can pull that up as we
speak to let you know
the growth uh representative spillsbury
it's a great question of saying
what is happening now are they
um overpaying their liability and
the cco is going to increase
because they're just keeping that funds
on file or is it a net decrease and
that's hard to tell until all returns
um until all returns are filed
if there's there's no way to know what
those taxpayers are doing
on a monthly basis with those estimates
if it's an overpayment or underpayment
until
until the returns until the returns are
filed
so just looking at um to give you some
perspective
for credit carryovers on file
i have in front of me which is our tax
expenditure report
fiscal year 16 it was 173.4 million
um fiscal year 17 it did decrease to
171.8 million
and then from fiscal year 17 on it has
increased fiscal year 18
196 million 19
fiscal year 19 was a big jump to 268.1
million
um and then fiscal year 20 is 271.6
just to give you some historical trends
okay
thank you on
i think it's pretty clear that on we
booked this money years ago
and we spent this money in budgets
so it is a revenue issue um
the the question is
how we get out of this and we have been
in this situation for two decades at
least
and probably longer than that um
and and i i think we do need to look
at percentages of um
what percentage would have to be
refunded
growing over a number of years whether
that would help
in the distribution of the pain on
but i did want to ask if maybe we could
try to
approach bill ortinger who presumably
talked to the governor about this
and maybe the head of the society of
cpas
about we've never
really explored this that i know of uh
how
why some of the businesses
are are keeping the money there
one of our ideas earlier was that that
if they had to pay it
to get it all back suddenly they were
going to have to pay higher taxes at the
federal level
the federal taxes have gone down
somewhat
considerably um but if
if maybe we could get an idea from them
of
why this is being kept it might help or
to figure out
how much of it is going to disappear
when
we did have a discussion a number of
years ago of why they were doing that
and i think it was
what they would have to pay on taxes if
they brought it back out
but representative romney would you take
over for a few minutes i've got to
stop uh drop off the next question am i
the next person
asking a question he wants you to take
over the committee
yeah am i know but um i guess i'm next
to ask the question so
this is for chris shea uh you know we
all we all look at the revenue focus
every month
in my understanding that revenue focus
is a cash document
so if credit carryovers in a particular
month
are exceed what they were the prior
that would show us a positive uh
income or positive revenue the show is
positive
in the revenue focus report now
something magical happens my
understanding is at the end of the year
where accrual accounting does come in
play somehow
can you can you just give us a quickie
on that uh
in terms of what we look at every month
is is cash
correct when we look at the credit
carryover
that reflects any delta change
from one month to another is that
correct so
so you're dealing on a cash basis every
month that you look at the revenue focus
and at the end of the year they do a
modified accrual
and that's where there's a
reconciliation that's performed against
the
carry credit forward which um as
uh deputy commissioner lear has
mentioned there's been some questions
over the years on how that's done
and you know is there a better way to do
that
between the auditors dra and and
treasurer and and
um the comptroller's office um
but i can't give you a whole lot more
than that that's it's kind of out of my
expertise area
um it's really something i would defer
to um carolyn if she's got more insight
or
we could have one one of our auditors
come on board to talk to you
or even the comptroller yes
well i think yeah i know we asked for
the treasurer
uh possibly the controller may be
helpful too so
yeah i can i can invite her as well and
see if um that they could be on the call
together maybe on
on um wednesday when you guys are
meeting
yep okay norma's back i like norm
[Music]
why don't we put it on the first thing
to do
on wednesday
well wednesday we we're oh that's right
we're having hearings on tuesday
hearings on those six senate bills on
tuesday
and we're gonna dedicate ourselves to
revenues
on wednesday and thursday
okay uh
there's no more hands on this further
question
representative nunes
thank you mr chairman uh i'm a freshman
on this committee so i just want to make
sure i've got all of the facts straight
on
on this issue that we're talking about
um
i've got some statements and questions i
just want to run over here and
and you guys can correct me if i'm wrong
but when we talk about whose money this
is this is the taxpayer money that we're
talking about correct
right and it's a credit carryover which
is an
overpayment by the taxpayer against
their tax liability from an estimate
that they used correct
okay so it can only be used to offset
the liability on the business tax
payment
correct
we need to get the the money that is in
this account
for each that of the overpayment by the
by the taxpayer by the business taxpayer
right
what's sitting out there and overpayment
that they can use to offset their tax
payment
can only be used for this purpose
correct
in the account can only be used to
offset
the business tax correct we need to get
that squared away with the treasure
okay can it be used for anything else by
the state while it's sitting in this
account
that needs to be answered by the
treasurer okay
and my last is more of a more of a
statement
why is the overpayment portion of this
reported as revenue
i'm done okay and and we do a cash basis
and then from the cash basis that's what
we see
as revenue now the accountants
take over after that so it would be nice
to get the squared away with the
with the treasury uh i think there i
think there is an issue here
okay uh representative
you muted susan while you were going
on we established it might be good to
have the comptroller as well
and i still think it might be worth
trying to talk with bill arden
since he represents a lot of the big
businesses
if he'd talk to us
we'll talk about that
and then uh after we understand
then we can talk to bill
the important thing for for
representative nunes is that
this has been recognized as an issue for
a while
these these credit carryovers are
getting so large
i think representative major and others
have been very concerned about this
uh now we got a proposal for a solution
the only problem the only question we're
trying to address now is
if if reducing this by 50 in one year or
whatever
you know look like there's going to be
some impact in a couple over a couple
years
that are significant are those cash
impacts
i think part of the answer is yes we're
going to be writing checks back to
people
we're going to be writing checks going
the other way
and that's going to be minus revenue the
way we seem to do our revenue so but
we're going to verify
all of that so yes this is an issue
that's been
out there and we
but all of a sudden we find an hb2
uh a solution and that we're trying to
grapple with
is the solution going to be how painful
is that solution going to be
to our revenues
i've been after the has done this for
years
of the various commissioners
i i found somebody
i think representative beat me to it
thank you representative ames and thank
you mr chair
if we're willing to and i hate to beat
this but it really is a fascinating
discussion but i don't mean to beat a
dead horse
if we're willing to refund the money to
the taxpayer
then we're willing to put the money in
escrow to ease
concerns about uh a mad rush of everyone
asking for refunds
but by automatically refunding this
money we sort of take a tool
out of the accountant's toolkit to
minimize new hampshire
businesses federal tax liability
so um it's just something we could
we should consider um and i look forward
to
continuing the discussion but it's
there's a lot of angles to this
representative followed by
representative ames
thank you mr chair um this the the idea
of the federal
um tax burden being increased
by getting the refund confuses me a bit
because
when i do my taxes if i don't ask for a
refund
i still get a 1099 g the next year
and it and that can add to my federal
tax liability so i'm not
i could be wrong but i don't think
whether it's refunded or not
affects the federal tax liability at
least in my own experience so i guess i
would like to hear
um also whether that's that's true or
not
that's a good question because when they
pay their taxes
that means that tax is deducted
from their earnings federally
and if they get a refund then they have
to put it back in
and take the taxes on it and it would be
nice to know if that's
the correct interpretation of this
representative
yeah i just wanted to say that this
discussion has been great and uh
it's it's revealed that this this
uh language uh
has an impact if it's not changed it
will have an impact
and uh um it's a negative impact on
revenues the way it's being expressed
right now
so that uh that needs to be understood
and factored in if it
uh or it can or it needs to be changed
um so
we need to get on top of this pretty
quickly you don't
know how well i feel when i hear you say
that
no
susan's smiling but she knows i've been
at it for many years
and this could have carried over
well anything that's going to carry over
if not let us move on
next has to do with section 135-136
which provides that proceeds from the
sale that resulted from money provided
by the highway fund
for payback of real property purchase
with federal funds
should be credited to the department of
transportation for the purpose of
meeting federal obligations or
reimbursing
the highway fund for payments of federal
obligations
chris you want to elaborate
so what i think i think all they're
trying to do there is include federal
um so essentially what happens when
the dot disposes of property and it gets
approved by the
long-range committee is that if it was
bought with highway funds or turnpike
funds
it goes back to that home fund in some
cases they have a matching federal
dollar
and the feds have allowed them to hold
that money and i think they're just
trying to
incorporate that into the statute that
um
allows them to dispose of property that
that if they do have something that was
bought with federal money and it's
allowable
they could deposit it into one of their
accounts be it the highway fund
turnpike fund or a separate account
so what i see on this item
is the only way it could affect revenues
to the highway
is is if they had other things that they
could sell
that would go the proceeds could go
directly to the highway fund and that
is something that the highway department
the department patient should be
managing
i don't see where sorry it
affects us i would agree represent major
it it's really it's just a way for them
to kind of retain the federal dollar
that
they might still be allowed to spend
still have to account for it it's it's
not going to um
help your revenues anywhere particularly
you know it might match a highway fund
purchase they might get permission to do
that
but i think they just wanted to um be
clear that when they do have federal
dollars
associated with a property that they're
holding it back that they're they're
just so it's accounted for
all right i don't see any questions so
we can move on
the next is 62
which is section 145 establish a body
worn and dashboard camera fun
that's strictly up to the
legislation the appropriators
and if they do then it would be
something that would be monitored by the
dedicated fund
next item
in section 163-164
amend the regenerative manufacturing
program into the workforce development
student debt relief program
makes various changes of the program
regarding definition
eligibility and established commission
to oversee the program
chris
what do you know about this um i know
nothing about this
um
[Laughter]
unfortunately i can't help you with this
at all i'd have to um
ask one of our budget guys who's been
working with division two of
house finance to see what information
they have related to this
could you and then get back to us yep
all right is that um
susan did you have any other items in
the hospital too
can i come back to this one because i
believe
that what the governor is doing is
taking
the arms fund that we spent quite a lot
of time on the
regenerated manufacturing program
and making it broadly into
a workforce development program
and we one of the problems that we had
with that
was that um they wanted
five million dollars to be spent in
student debt relief which is mentioned
here
on for the arms fund so that they'd have
more people coming
in to it on and
they were on they wanted
the new hampshire business finance
authority
to um find a way to get the money
to spend on this and
when it left our hands and
for a year after when i was following up
they hadn't figured out a way to get
that money
so the question is do we have
anything to do with this since it came
out of our committee in the first place
or do we just leave it to someone else
to try to figure out how you find
money to pay for it chris is going to
find out what do they want to do here
what this
is about i know that
when we had the regenerative
manufacturing and set aside
five million dollars for tuition refund
for those people
that are going to be employed in the
regenerative manufacturing
as tuesday to tourism refunds
i think we need to get more information
before we can go any further with this
and we'll try to have that available for
wednesday
did you when you looked at hospital too
did you have any other items
in addition to what's been put together
well there was a question which we can
probably leave to the dedicated
fund program uh committee
on about the state heating system
but it's probably okay the thing that
on their the department of education is
supposed to accept
gifts and bequests to fund new hampshire
scholars
for an accounting unit which ought to be
a dedicated fund
and there
is in the index a reference to a
transfer
to the education trust fund which is
actually a transfer
from the education trust fund to the
public school
infrastructure fund which was created in
and on there are a lot of errors in that
drafting
i don't know if the
on lbao is is working on that
aside from the first error which is the
index
reference but those were the
the main other things i do think
we ought to tell them about the 612s but
um
rather than leave it to be cleaned up
later
but i can i can do that myself
okay has any anybody else in looking at
house bill 2
come up with any items we haven't
discussed
relative to that's going to affect
revenues
norm i've had my hand up representative
brownlee
uh well yeah uh just on on that
advanced regenerative manufacturing
first i mean
jennifer has a footnote here that says
this isn't typical
ways and means policy change but she
just included it
because we were so involved with with uh
regenerative manufacturing
which brings me to may not be a bad idea
uh when things slow down a bit in maybe
april and may
that we invite army over to give us an
update on
how the whole advanced regenerative
manufacturing
program is going this is an aside from
this so
uh this has triggered that thought
that's a good idea
so but here's my thing that the one
other thing they had on the sheet
was the addition of two of dra auditors
and there was a positive revenue impact
from that uh not on not on the sheet
that jennifer generated but on the
the budget sheet that we worked off
about a month ago
so they talked about a 0.7
million dollar increase in revenue
on 22 and 3.2 million dollar increase in
revenue in
23. the question i have is do we is this
something we want to report
uh verify and then report to finance
i think it should be myself but um
this is like a because they're going to
they're the ones who are going to
finalize
whether they're they're going to prove
those additional order positions
for the r8
yeah and there were different categories
of auditors
and the amount was
700 022 and 3.2 million
23. right right i mean
dra could explain that if you want them
to or we could just accept that
um melissa or carolyn
carolyn lehrer assistant commissioner at
the department of revenue
um the the two additional auditor
positions
um were specifically i believe
multi-state
auditors um these are the auditors that
um audit our largest
business uh the largest multinational
businesses and um we did provide
those revenue estimates
smaller in year one because of the
training requirements and the amount of
time that it takes for auditors to get
up to speed
but those are also our highest revenue
producing auditors because of the size
of the company that they typically audit
so a much larger impact in year two
but those numbers were directly from us
based on our
estimates based on prior experience
right and that's a total of five
positions
but but the the heavy positions of the
multi national auditors
that's right i believe um we typically
expect them to generate around a million
to a million and a half
um in revenue a year once they're up and
running
and um lindsay did present i'm sorry
commissioner steph did present
yesterday to division one in house
finance
um and gave them this information as
well so they do
have the information about the expected
revenue from those positions
so they have these numbers they do okay
anybody else in looking at house bill 2
or legislation
you feel
can affect revenue that could possibly
be used in hospital
too all right
i think we did all right this morning
does anybody else have anything else
they want to bring up
we going to deal with single
satisfactory today
what's that we're going to deal with
single sales factor today
oh yeah um
did you want to do that right now or
take a break
if does that if it's the last thing
maybe we should just get it done
okay then let's do that
since we have the dra here
you want me to introduce this
norm yeah um i want to
grab my folder on it here we go
go ahead uh representative
so uh ways and means passed house bill
a month or so ago went on consent
calendar was 22 nothing vote
um that was to move out the date of
single sales factor
from taxable periods ending on or after
december 31st 2022
moving that out to december 31st of 2026
and that that way we would have more
time to evaluate the impact
of of market-based sourcing
before we took the next step to single
sales factor
and this was all as a result of house
bill 4 the last budget
where the senate put in single sales
factor we never really had an earrings
on it
etc so and we're we're
we're as a house uh ways and means we
tend to be a little more
uh conservative about about some of
these things and
want more proof i guess
[Music]
but we did our revenue estimates
i think most of us and i i can recall
the conversations
were cognizant of house bill
i mean of uh of single sas factor going
into
into play especially in fiscal 2023
and i think our estimates were based on
that
now in conversations with lynn ober
uh once you understood house bill 281
said that wow why don't we just put 281
in house bill two
but if we were to do that would that
have what impact would that have on the
business taxes
especially for fiscal 2023 now my
and i i said well look i can only give
you my opinion
but we can meet as a committee to talk
about this
um i know when i looked at my numbers
that i used
that i factored in monies for
uh uh i should say reduced my estimates
for 2023 because of single sales factor
so what i'd like to if we can as a group
today
uh come to a consensus as to
first do we think that if we put this
to uh 281 into
into the house bill 2 basically delaying
the single sales factor would people
feel comfortable and also
uh increasing our revenue estimates
for 23. um that's the question on the
table
and you got to remember that the day of
dra's low estimate was 840.1
million and the high was this is then
they increased it since then but i think
we got to go to back to
what we were working with a month ago uh
the high was 899.8
uh but we when we took the democrat
average and the republican average came
up with 840 million
so we were at the at the absolute low
end of the dra
number okay now normally we don't go
that low
and i think part of the reason we want
that low is cause a single sales factor
i did quiz dra the other day
about their estimates their original
estimates of
840.1 to 899.8
and they did not factor in anything for
single sales factor okay so uh
basically uh because they felt it wasn't
indeterminable
and we'll like if they could speak for
themselves on this but
that there'd be years that it would be
good in years that may be bad
but i know as a committee
we took the view that it was going to be
bad in terms of reducing revenues
now you could all correct me that
that i was wrong and that in that
statement but i know personally
i did and if i my recollection of the
conversations
i think others did as well so
um i mean i i i think there's
i mean if we took it as a if we let's
pause one number
so we can have a conversation around it
i mean
the midpoint of the dras estimate
did not factor in single sales factor
um the midpoint was uh
869.95 million
and if if
we say we could hit that midpoint
that's about a 29.95 million difference
from
our estimate that we did so let's call
it 30 million because
let's round it so
i i think there's something here if
if we want again dear
the finances willing to put this in hb2
but they want to know a number so if if
we were to do that
would we increase our our revenue
estimates
assuming there's no single sales factor
so i'd just like to open up the
discussion
and uh you know
with the fact that this single sales
factor would be put on hold for a couple
years
make a difference in folks revenue
estimates
well the dra came out with revised
estimates as of yesterday
and for fy23
they have 847.7
as the low and 907.3 is the high
and in these estimates
melissa or caroline
was there any impact for
single sales factor
representative major this is carolyn
lear assistant commissioner
there is no accounting for the
impact of single sales factor
apportionment
in our revenue estimates
and then your your percentages that you
use from growing
from 22 to 21
it was four percent on the low and and
six percent of the high
uh then
on 22
well actually we really need to go right
back to 21
21 your estimate was 817 to 841.
and then you grew that by one percent
and three percent on the low and the
high
going to 22. and then another four
percent
and six percent for the high end low
going to 23.
and there was no
effect on single sales factor
at that point in time that's correct our
growth
percentages did not take into
consideration
any impact from single sales factor
and your revenue estimates that you came
out with yesterday
is based upon what you know as of
yesterday
relative to the collection of revenues
and the estimates today
and the economy all these things you've
taken those into account
the the revenue estimates that melissa
sent you yesterday and she can jump in
as well
the only change in those estimates i
believe
was to um
change february to actual february
receipts
melissa do you want to jump in and
elaborate on that
did they take the tax notice out of that
sure for the record melissa rollins
department of revenue
um yes the carolyn is absolutely correct
the only change we did was to remove the
february estimate that we had to replace
with actual february
in representative major to your point um
i think it was noted in the email
that we did remove the anomalous payment
out of the base when growing fiscal year
22 we removed
10 million dollars knowing that that
wouldn't continue or we didn't
anticipate that to continue
in fiscal year 22.
we did not change any of our further
assumptions we haven't dug into
anything we intend to do that as march
comes in and we have some more data
okay and hopefully
when we meet on the
18th you may have some data that's
i hope and the reason we
we have to do something by the 18th
is because the finance committee has to
be complete by early the next week
mr chair there's two separate issues on
the table
there's next week's discussion about any
revenue estimate changes
and then there's our discussion today
about did we or did we not
factor in if we were to take out single
sales factor
from our discussion as if as in hold
put a hold on it what in our revenues
estimates have been higher when we did
our original estimates
that's what i'm trying to get at right
so what you're trying to get is what did
we factor in for a single sales factor
and 23.
right and i know we must have factored
in something because i know
we would not have been at 800 and
uh our our our combined republican
democrat
average was 840 million
which is
uh you know the minimum at the dra level
why would we go why would we base
we never have done this where we go to
the minimum
of what the era said at the time not not
their
not their new estimates at the time of
840 million
so it's low uh very low
uh and i to me
it was that we we were hedging our bets
on single sales factor
so if we're going to put a hold on
single sales factor
my my gut tells me we should be
increasing these
these estimates yes but the question is
how much if they put it into hb2 uh
hospital 281
and how much did a single sales factor
affect
our revenue estimate for 23.
mr chairman you have representative
spillsberry and then you have me
oh okay representative spellsbury thank
you mr chairman and
representative holly um yeah
just to confirm what pat is asking i had
the deferral of single sales factor
in mind in setting the estimates so i
i understand the path he's trying to
lead us on it makes sense
my freshman question is uh
i'm not clear as a matter of procedure
what the advantages and disadvantages
are
as to having hb 281
go through the senate process
independently versus getting
incorporated into the budget
is there an advantage for example
allowing the
finance committee to uh bank that
into the budget or what is the issue one
way or the other
what it is is they want they want more
revenue
by putting into the budget if they uh
let's say we attracted 12 million
dollars
so by incorporating it into hb2 that can
take account of the revenue effect
right so that thank you for each year
they could raise the
revenues that they have to play with by
12 million
also answer that question norm yes the
odds of the senate
agreeing with us on 281 is minimal
given that this was their position last
year
to go to single sales factor
does this help putting it into hp2 yeah
it makes it a bigger fight
i guess um you know the power brokers
that be
that are going to ultimately
you know do whatever they do at the end
of this budget negotiation
uh you know we could win this fight by
having it in hb2 uh
and that and you know we're giving you
we're giving the
we're giving the house more money to to
work with
i know they'll be fighting pretty hard
and the house finance guys
on this to keep this in uh
how much we
put into our estimate
to account for a single sales factor
on fy23
i think we're going to have to go back
to our notes
in the meantime representative
follow me thank you
on i actually had an estimate that was 5
million
lower than than
the democrats put into the to the heap
went along with the rest of them it was
based
on the single sales factor and
it was based on a very conservative
version
of what happened in 2018
when all of that extra um
tax money went back to the major
corporations that we deal with from the
federal government
and we got to tax it on
i took half of what that produced which
was 68
million and then i cut it down to 30
which is exactly what
representative abrami was talking about
from a different angle
on and struck that loss
into to my personal estimate
and i do feel that
the largest corporations though we don't
know
what their mix is that's the trouble and
dra can't tell us
but that they have been doing quite well
during the pandemic and are positioned
to do quite well
after the pandemic and that
on they are the ones that
that end up making more
more than uh off of this
than the the small corporations
according to what we were
were given and that they make
on 10 million of the loss
is given to them alone
and the rest of it is split between the
large and the small total corporations
so the total loss that i was using was
30 million
which is what representative abrami came
at
from a different different uh
[Music]
calculations due to the single sales
factor
um it is it's very been very variable
in their calculations in the past we
don't know
and i think i took the five million off
extra of the
six million off extra from that because
um we get some money back from
market-based sourcing
on that they're pretty sure of but they
haven't i think that's
also not put into the dra revenue
estimate
yeah because they haven't got a final
calculation on it
so oh and i did want to say that i think
that
having it in hb2 puts the finance
committee of the house
behind this when we go into committee
conference
and they're the ones who get to talk
mostly about
what happens in that committee of
conference and make the decisions
and i'm hoping that if we can get a
hearing
in the senate that maybe um with the
information from 2018 that they will be
feeling more cautious
as senator d'alessandro seemed to be
feeling more cautious when we had
those um that special committee
in november
okay representative ames
thank you um
yeah i really hope that uh that fine
house finance will put
into house bill 2 this delay of
single sales factor
and i do think at least in my case
the likelihood the single sales factor
would be a negative
factored into my uh
personal input into that uh
group calculation that we did
as a as a negative um i
i think that it should i would hope that
it would be possible
uh representative major to convey
to the finance committee the sense of
this committee
at the sense the conviction of this
committee that
a single sales factor delay will be a
positive for
revenue without getting into
[Music]
providing a number um at least until
after we've done a calculation that
looks at the whole picture because i
know when i was doing my estimates i was
you know the the the single sales factor
was a negative but there were positives
and
it all sort of comes together and
combined calculation in a way that's
hard to repeat
we're going to be trying to do that next
week i think
um and yet yet we need to communicate
with finance
now why couldn't we do it in this more
sort of general way
um if indeed what i just said about the
committee's position is accurate
do you can you attribute
a certain amount just to the single
sales factor
well um i'm hesitant to do that but i
wouldn't say 30 million
if it would be in the positive terrain
and be five or ten million dollars but
it might be more after we do a group
discussion on it
um
then over seems to
think it's 12.99 where did she get that
number from
what was that twelve point nine what
twelve don't know
what they were in the sales factor
who
chris
is chris still with us
i am just trying to unmute
um i don't know where reps of over got
the number at 12.9
but that sounds like the historical
racing number
so we'd have to check in with her on
that right it's the historical racing
they want to put that in the house
too
1229 is close to the average
loss over 14 to 17 before they had the
data for 18
before market-based sourcing which is
the key
problem
so the 12.9 is associated with historic
all racing we we have some work to do
can we give him some kind of a range
don't norm
they're going to want a number tomorrow
if they're going to do this
if i don't know if we don't give them a
number they may not they may not do it
unless they can wait for a week what are
you saying representative ames that
as we do a more detailed dive on
wednesday and thursday
that we keep this in the back of our
minds as we're going through this
and you would feel more comfortable at
the end of next week
estimating uh the impact
in your mind of a single sales factor
um yeah i
uh i i don't know what to say the uh um
what we what the data that we have is
the historical data that representative
army has
pointed to which has different numbers
by year very substantial numbers in the
most recent year
that are above the number we're talking
about
then we got market-based sourcing uh
coming into the picture
and uh confusing things
uh it does add up for me
so also based on my understanding of the
role of manufacturing
and sort of businesses that are likely
to
pay less tax with single sales factor
it all adds up to a negative how much of
a negative
i wish i knew um but uh
if you're asking for a number why not
12.9
uh no i i don't know
you know it's it's that arbitrary but uh
12.9 or
or 10 i'd say i'd round at 10
would be to me a comfortable number
i think it is in the 30 million range
but i mean we could put a lower
uh give them a range of 10 to 20 or
something like that
i'm comfortable with that i think
they're going to have to have a number
that they can put into the surplus
statement
even though we don't know what it is
we're going to have to
give them a number just like we did for
the revenue estimate
chris did they talk about a number
tall for this um i don't
know what the discussions has been about
this uh single sales factor in adding
the bill in
but reps on volume is correct in the
sense that the the
finance committee want a single number
if you provided a range they would
probably take the midpoint of the range
to add to a surplus statement
or they might take high point of the
range if they're looking for revenue so
if you want to control that to some
extent you may want to provide a single
number if you want to give them the
ability to kind of choose between the
range then you can
provide um i think it's just an ongoing
discussion right now and i think that
i i was under the impression that some
of the division chairs are waiting on
this committee to make some decisions
around what the impact might be if they
added that bill
to house bill 2.
how about somebody else wants to
give their opinion
i don't know if they have their notes in
front of them
roxanna elliott
well i've heard the 30 million
uh figure and i've heard the 10 million
dollar figure
um and i'm just wondering if
we could all agree on splitting the
difference and making it
a figure of 20 million
the dollars southwest yes that's what i
was thinking as well
again there are many many uh variables
to consider but
that seems like a reasonable compromise
20 million
um representing southwest uh
no that's very
okay represents spillsberry thank you mr
chairman
i truly feel like i'm stabbing in the
dark on this one
um 10 million i feel comfortable with
20 million i'd go along with but i'm
the echo that keeps going on in my mind
as we're having this discussion
is those carry forwards and
uh the idea that uh
effectively people are going to be asked
to
chip those down whether it's a refund
check check or whether it's lowering
their estimates
um so that's part of this discussion as
well
anybody else
i just say that these are separate
discussions
that all add up to a number
at the end the carry forward issue is
gonna
also it's pr i i hope it's going to be
at least amended
but we really don't want to put it off
too much longer
mom why don't we just go with the 20
million and let you know others haven't
weighed in i mean
uh they all have to let's go with the 20
million for now
and let us review it next week
and so that our our
number would be instead of
uh what was it eight forty yeah
well it would be sixty
point one what would it be
instead of eight forty it was eight
forty
point one from the razor bike by twenty
so it'd be eight 860. yeah
let's just call it 860.
but the economic situation has been
changing also so
the base may change next week
the uh there isn't anything that i
see in economics that is
turning negative right now
not anything so i agree with that
so uh what did you say what did you say
mr chairman i don't i haven't
heard of anything at this point in time
economic wise that's trending negative
thank you which means we may want to
raise our base
yes and we'll talk about that
wednesday and thursday
so do your homework
between now and then
and by by your homework that means just
don't look at the numbers
look at the papers look at magazines
look
listen to the economist listen to the
personal people listen
job report all that
all right anything else we
want to bring up today
then we'll call it quick for the day and
then we've got the afternoon
and so next week we're meeting on
tuesday wednesday thursday is that
correct
that's correct thank you tuesday
is a public hearing
on the senate on the six senate bills
that are coming in
so what you need to do is load those
bills look them over prior to
the public hearing on tuesday
and wednesday we'll primarily be meeting
with the dra
the treasurer and the comptroller and
probably have
uh hardinger come in
then thursday we may continue
on with the people that we talked with
we still need them and then
anybody else that we need to bring in
ages other types of agencies
yes uh that amendment on 614
the the one that was supposed to be
voted on can we have a copy of that
uh that was that was uh sent by
uh representative vose yeah i
i don't have a
let's ask for it i'm not sure i i do
know what's in it but uh you're
absolutely right we need to make sure we
get that
uh that amendment i'll get that
out thank you all right thank you
make a note right now bullary has his
hand up
thank you
oh thank you uh with mary being
it would ring just then
with mary being sick uh should we get
together
in some fashion and send her a card or
some flowers i'll be glad to undertake
that
um from the committee would the
committee like to do something like that
yes yes yes
how do we get money to you
we can't pass the hat these days
don't worry about it until session no
big deal i'll i'll uh
oh what do you say oh you put it in the
presentation
carryover yeah do you want to do um
sherry's berries or just plain flowers
or what
what would you guys like to do
trust you yes
is she allergic to strawberries
i don't think so representative major i
just looked quickly for his email and it
has
amendment 222 h
that's correct um okay
all right i'll i'll take care of that
and put it from the committee then
thank you thank you i'll have jen
look up that amendment and get it out to
the members of the committee
yeah all right
we did in that case get it from
representative vo's but it's back
several emails it was yesterday i did a
copy of it out i do have it i have it
in the email the 222 because we do have
it if that's
0-2-2-2-h
so when you say that there there is
nothing negative
on the economic front
we have the country split exactly in two
on the opinion of on the what
we have a bill that has
half half the congress
not supporting it and half supporting it
i
i think there's i think there's a lot to
discuss
it's a very different economic package
that we're facing
and we will be discussing that stimulus
i think it's uh and and this
state is quite split
a lot of states are split well
but i only have to think about new
hampshire
i was the economic output
what's happening more the unemployment's
coming down
the jobs number drops going up
the more businesses are
opening people
spending money the personal income is
up stock markets up
and a number of other indicators are in
the positive
direction doesn't mean they're going to
stay there
but they're positive right now
and finally the vaccination systems are
working better
my second shot today when the
vaccination
and uh
biden has just made a contract for 100
million
of the johnson and johnson charts
in addition to what's coming so
that the more of those shots there are
one timer
that means that person is completely
vaccinated
versus the pfizer and
so it's coming it's in a positive
direction
anything else anybody wants to talk
about before
all right thank you
and have a good day thank you
i'm gonna i'm hoping that i get a
picture of my
great great granddaughter that's
exciting that's great
what is your name her name is
aubry mary grant demarco
wonderful beautiful
i'm excited congratulations oh thank you